فرص السلام تبدو صعبه في الشرق الاوسط
ولكن من الممكن التفكير في مسارات متنوعه
للاقتراب من هدف
السلام المسار الاول هو التوافق العام
داخل فلسطين وداخل اسرائيل
على تجريم قتل المدنيين لا يمكن ان تكون
هناك اي فرصه للسلام او للتقارب او
للتفكير في حل للصراع دون توافق على تجريم
قتل المدنيين بدون شروط وبدون
قيود المسار الثاني
هو محاوله البحث عن الترتيبات الافضل
لقطاع غزه ما ان تنتهي الحرب وهو وما
اتمنى ان يكون في القريب العاجل سواء
انتهت الحرب بصيغه هدنه مؤقته تمتد الى
اجل زمني اطول او انتهت الحرب بصيغه
انتهاء الحرب بترتيب ما سيصبح الاهم
لتحقيق السلام هو التوافق حول ترتيبات
الفتره الوسيطه ما الذي سيحدث في غزه فيما
بعد وفي في غزه تحديات كبرى هي الوضع
الانساني فاستمرار المساعدات وزياداتها
ضروري جدا تحول المساعده الانسانيه الى
جهود
للاعمار البحث عن الطريقه الافضل فلسطينيا
للاستماع الى اصوات الشعب الفلسطيني في
غزه وعدم تهميشهم في كل حديث عن مستقبل
غزه فمستقبل غزه لن يتحدد في اسرائيل ولا
يتحدد في الولايات المتحده ولا في اي
عاصمه اخرى ولكن يحددوا الشعب الفلسطيني
وبالتالي احد التحديات الكبرى في في
الفتره الوسيطه هو اعاده لحمه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بين غزه والضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه والالتفات الى ما يحدث في الضفه
من عنف مستمر مازال ا يتكاثر ويتصاعد
ولابد من ايقاف هذا العنف المسار الاخير
على المستوى الطويل هناك دور كبير للعالم
العربي في دول في العالم العربي لها خبره
دبلوماسيه ولها قدرات على التفاوض وصناعه
السلام والوساطه بين الطرفين بين الطرف
الفلسطيني والطرف الاسرائيلي مصر قطر
السعوديه
ا
الامارات المغرب الدول التي تجمع بين
علاقات جيده مع الطرف الاسرائيلي والطرف
الفلسطيني وخبره دبلوماسيه متراكمه لابد
من التعويل على هذه الاطراف لطرح مبادره
سلام عربيه جديده تعرض التطبيع والسلام
مقابل الدوله الفلسطينيه على 4 يونيو